le son d'une déchiqueteuse un son qui
occupe et rassure olivier sauriol soufre
est un peu dur au début de la pandémie
il de voir qui était tellement choquée
puis de pas comprendre ce qui se passait
olivier sauriol vie avec la trisomie 21
est une déficience intellectuelle qui
limite son langage à la mi mars
le jeune homme de 23 ans est coupé de sa
route s'élève de madère trois jours dans
une école spécialisée et deux jours de
stage à loto-québec eu des moments
d'anxiété beaucoup d'anxiété vieux
sauter sur place continuellement
marchait dans la maison sans arrêt à ces
stages à loto-québec mon il faisait le
déchiquetage qui aimait beaucoup de
lieux comme ses parents il travaille de
la maison la famille commence à nous
donner des papiers puis je suivais ça
serait une bonne idée de parts une
petite entreprise c'est ainsi qu'est née
olivères déchiquetage le service est
gratuit et permet à olivier de sortir un
peu pour aller chercher sa matière
première chez les voisins aujourd'hui ça
va bien oui avec une maman raciste le
logo de l'hiver a rapidement pris fort
j'avais juste son visage
un manège s'apprend le pouce parce
qu'olivier fait continuellement
je me suis rendu compte qu'elle était
fière aussi d'aller chercher les boîtes
il va y voit les gens qui sourient
oui et l'autre en hiver jouit maintenant
d'une certaine renommée
[Musique]
ça a été une publication la plus
populaire à vie en 2003 sans partage ça
la touche et 180 mille personnes cette
belle histoire là de la journée de la
publication on a eu des messages à notre
porte facebook comme ça et on a vu ce
papier nous est ce qu'on peut lui
apporter ce qui peut venir à québec en
chercher à trois rivières il va pas
manquer de papier en tout cas pas pour
un beau but pour qu'olivier puisse faire
oeuvre utile jusqu'au bout les retail a
cumulé une feuille à la fois iront au
centre de récupération pour l'encourager
la compagnie google lui a proposé une
victime et non de sa prochaine livraison
ici à nourrice despatie radio canada
montréal
[Musique]